up close but not close enough for
activists the un's human rights chief is
accused of failing to press china on
alleged atrocities during her six-day
visit michelle bachelet insists she
wasn't there to investigate and beijing
denies any wrongdoing so did the trip
have any purpose this is inside store
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm kim
vannell michelle bachelet has been
denounced by activists in her field
after the first trip to china by a u.n
human rights chief in 17 years
bachelet's tightly controlled visit took
her to xinjiang region where the u.s has
labeled the detention of uyghur muslims
and other minorities as genocide she
admitted being unable to assess the
scale of any human rights abuses but
said she discussed it with officials
china denies committing any crimes
saying it set up training centers in
xinjiang not detention camps this was
not an investigation
official visit by a high commissioner
are by their nature high profile and
simply not conducive to the kind of
detail methodology methodology
methodical discrete work of an
investigative nature
the visa was an opportunity to hold
direct discussions with china's most
senior leaders on human rights to listen
to each other raise concerns explore and
pave the way for more regular meaningful
interactions in the future
well human rights watch executive
director kenneth roth describes himself
as proudly sanctioned by chinese
government he posted his assessment of
bachelet's trip on twitter
said the un rights chief seems to
believe she is so persuasive that her
quiet backroom conversation will
convince beijing to ease its repression
but beijing will gladly talk privately
until she is blue in the face
it will respond only to public pressure
china though says the trip delivered
concrete results and dismissed criticism
by those they say make up lies about
xinjiang under the guise of human rights
in recent years there's been a tendency
of politicizing and instrumentalizing
the un human rights council and other
multilateral human rights institutions
china has made it very clear that some
western countries while having no
self-reflection on their own notorious
misdeeds yet driven by political motives
abuse multilateral human rights
platforms to spread rumors and lies
using human rights to interfere in
others domestic affairs and recklessly
attacking and smearing others turning
multilateral human rights institutions
into arenas of naming and shaming and
block confrontation
these behaviors have gravely poisoned
the atmosphere of the international
human rights cooperation and must be
taken seriously
all right let's bring in our guests from
washington dc roushan abbas the
executive director of campaign for
uighurs in beijing is aina tangen a
senior international fellow at the
taihei institute who specialises in
china affairs and sophie richardson is
the china director at human rights watch
and joins us also from washington a very
warm welcome to you all thank you for
joining us here on inside story i'd like
to start with you roshan abbas uh
because as well as being the executive
director
of campaign for weakers you also have
family members who have uh gone missing
or been detained including your sister i
just want to
start by asking you to tell us what what
happened to your sister what do you know
um thank you so much kim for giving me
this opportunity in september 2018
i participated on a panel
in one of the think tanks in washington
dc the hudson institute and i spoke
against china's genocidal policies
while outlining the faith of my in-laws
which my husband's entire family was
missing my parents-in-laws in their 70s
and 3 of my husbands sisters and their
husbands and brother and his wife and 14
of my husbands nieces and nephews
all went missing since the summer of
2017.
but
just six days after that panel after i
exposed china's
policies my own sister
dr gulshan abbas she was taken by the
chinese government as retaliation for my
advocacy
she's a medical doctor retired medical
doctor she retired and early age due to
health reasons from practicing medicine
in two weeks from now she will be 60
years old
but i have no idea where she's being
held at
i don't know
if she's still alive
not only she's being
taken as a hostage as a retaliation for
my activism abroad but also
she is being charged harshly
at the beginning when i was vocal about
my sister's case and raised her case in
media the chinese state-owned media the
china global times network accused me
for stealing someone else's photo and
spreading lies about my missing sister
then we learned on christmas day in 2020
that my sister dr buchanabas was
sentenced to 20 years in prison on the
terrorism-related charges i know there
is a kind people
non-political person there has been
confirmation i know uh from beijing
about her detention um thank you for
sharing that with us sophie richardson
i'd like to cross over to you just to
give our viewers a um a sort of wider
perspective on everything that's
happening in xinjiang what do we
actually know
is happening there what has been proven
without a shadow of a doubt
uh the scale of what is happening in in
xinjiang
first thanks for having me human rights
watch has been documenting serious
chinese government human rights
violations
uh in that region since 1997
but in the last five years we have had
to focus on
the authority's misuse it's it's it's
overreach
uh of using
the pretext of terrorism
to arbitrarily detain upwards of a
million people
wholly outside of any sort of legal
proceedings and purely on the basis of
their ethnicity and their religion we've
documented torture we've documented
family separations cultural persecution
enforced disappearances
and these do rise to the level of crimes
against humanity and it is imperative
that the international human rights
system particularly in the form of u.n
human rights mechanisms respond to this
not as the u.n high commissioner has
offered through a working group but
rather through an actual credible
investigation with a view towards
accountability proceedings let's be very
clear that if any other government in
the world
was committing human rights abuses of
this scope and this scale we would be
well underway with that project but
because the chinese government has used
its power in the international system
and particularly within the un
we're not any closer
to roshan's sister being freed
and that's not
we will be talking about um michelle
bachelet's trip in a moment but first
i'd like to cross over to aina tangen
um
so china says that these uh camps are
re-education camps what does that mean
what is the chinese narrative here
chinese narrative is that there were a
series of incidences between uh
basically uyghurs attacking hans
not only in xinjiang there was an
incident where a bunch of
pan chinese were slaughtered on a subway
station
down south by a group of
uyghur terrorists
and they decided that you know they
needed to take things in order what they
decided was that
like in every other part of china
uyghurs needed to understand chinese
they needed to be mainstreamed they
needed to have an education many
families they had multiple wives
multiple children which was you know
useful when you're in agriculture but a
lot of these areas it doomed them to
agriculture and unfortunately what
happens is when you have a lot of
children and there's only so much land
the ability to support those children
goes down as you go down by generations
so
there was this fear and that was founded
in this kind of radical elements that
were
saying that they wanted an independent
xinjiang that they were joining uh
terrorist organizations and also
struggles in the middle east uh that
they did not want that in china so they
said education is the key
and we have to make sure that they speak
chinese so that they are they can are
portable they can they are not you know
restricted to xinjiang where they can
speak a local dialect they really need
to um to be mainstreamed so this is what
uh china thought was the answer
mr tangan the international community
and it's been documented by various uh
human rights groups pretty obvious
according to all of those reports that
these are in fact not
uh re-education camps but that there are
some serious human rights abuses
happening in those camps and as we've
heard you know people just disappearing
their families don't know where they are
so what has been china's response to
that well you know you you you mentioned
that kim that that you these this has
been established um quite frankly if you
start looking at all the paperwork
that's been put together and
i have no doubt that human rights
watches is collecting data from
different sources i certainly don't have
people on the ground there
um but you know it all comes back to
this gentleman named adrian zens
somebody who is uh thoroughly anti
he's a born-again christian um he
believes not a very big fan of women's
rights he believes in corporal
punishment
um it's strange that he would adopt
muslims as he believes under his own
you know very extreme brand of
christianity that they're all going to
hell
but i mean he emerges in 2018 as an
expert on xinjiang matters and it's
through him that you hear all these
allegations and someone who puts out
this there's a million uyghurs in
concentration camps uh how he did this
he interviewed eight people
and based on those eight people he
extrapolated and decided there was a
million he decided that he was also the
source that said that xinjiang women
were being
reproductive rights are being terminated
forcefully against their will
he also was the one who said that
xinjiang cotton was being harvested by
you know this million
person uh group of
people he said were in detention
so uh and it's been surprisingly
unsurprising i should say just prior to
michelle bachelet's visit he says he has
a treasure trove of uh documents and
pictures uh showing that there are
active abuses going on in xinjiang
uh it's strange uh in terms of the
timing it's also strange that he's
employed by the jamestown foundation
which was founded to uh by the cia to
help soviet emigres uh find a voice and
a job in the united states
so you know if it
i just want to interrupt you there i
just want to interrupt you there because
without having mr zens on the program to
defend himself i should just add that he
has said that there is a propaganda
smear campaign against him and and his
uh his research um but as i said when we
don't have him on the program here to to
defend himself there has of course been
a lot of other research done beyond what
mr zen's uh has has started and which
has been built upon that um i want to uh
come back to you can you name that kim
can you can you specify that well why
don't we cross it why don't we cross
sure sure why don't we cross back over
that's when we go back to human rights
yeah let's go back to human rights watch
sophie richardson if you can uh tell us
a little bit more about the the uh
irrefutable evidence
well
we can go on for quite some time about
the thousands of uyghurs we have
interviewed over the last 25 years and
particularly the hundreds including camp
survivors uh in the recent past i find
some of these comments a little bit uh
bizarre at best i also want to point out
on the topic of
re-education camps
and thinking especially of people like
dr gulshan abbas or the very well-known
uyghur economist ilham toti
who is a you know a scholar
uh you know i i don't think that doctors
and lawyers uh need re-education
uh let's be very clear about what we
have documented based on victim and
survivor testimony has happened in these
camps
torture
denial of food and medical treatment
uh sexual violence
a forced
study of xi jinping thought and
renunciation of faith and culture
persecution for using the weaker
language forcing uh older people to
study mandarin and not use weaker
so so let's let's take the gloss off
this term re-education this is torture
and these are crimes against humanity
and we have documented it directly from
the people who actually have experienced
it there is irrefutable evidence i think
maybe we can point particularly in this
discussion to the number of chinese
government documents that have leaked
over the last several years showing
among other things the intent to
arbitrarily detain people
uh in large scale
and particularly with a view towards
essentially
eradicating uyghurs and other turkic
communities distinct identities these
are crimes against humanity and they
require
a serious response as we see in other
parts of the world all right thank you
for that mr richardson i want to cross
over to roshan abbas because the purpose
of this program we want to get on to is
talking about the un's efforts in china
um the un human rights commission is
trip to china roshan abbas uh what are
your thoughts on michelle bashley's
going to china was it a mistake as the
u.s contends
it is a mistake and we have been asking
her to meet with us as the victims
families and meet with the former
inmates who were in the camps before but
she refused meeting with us and with her
statement yesterday at the press
conference
it's you know what she said is appalling
and as a sister of a
victim innocent victim being detained i
am offended we are hurt as a uyghurs
beyond the disappointment
what the bachelet did
is an
abandonment of her obligation
it's an insult to
the camp victims and millions of
innocent orders who are missing and the
suffering
and the being sent to modern slavery
and also
it's a betrayal of the founding
principles of the united nations and the
values that she is commanded with
upholding
so and it's a perfect example of the
united nation and her office and the
michelle bachelet
voluntarily giving up
the rights to defend freedom and
democracy so we are calling for her
resignation immediately okay she
mimicked tcp's talking points like
anti-terrorism
and her narrative basically legitimized
the genocide perpetrated against the
uyghurs and her so-called prison visit
is a potential style of sham and there
is overwhelming proof of what's
happening as sophie justice said with
eyewitness testimonies and former
victims and also document after document
of the chinese government's own leaked
data
and it's showing
the pcr's intent equals republic of
china's intent
for the genocide and her comments
yesterday seemed custom-made with the uh
people's republic of china's propaganda
mission okay
i'd like to i'd like to
i'd like to cross over back to anna
tangan uh uh just to talk a little bit
more about michelle bachelet's visit how
do you think china will be will be
viewing this visit is is this a success
for them well i don't know that it's a
success i mean uh basically they avoided
the lynching that was being referred to
by uh
rashaan um yes i mean that that that's
always good i mean we do there is a lot
of anecdotal uh uh testimony uh by
people who are seeking asylum in other
countries uh they can't exactly say that
you know life and uh back home was
wonderful they they want to put the best
loss on it they can as they're looking
to go somewhere else
so uh what you have here is she's uh i i
guess
the premise is that she's somehow in
league with the chinese government i i
don't think anybody who knows her or
as a head of state who's seen her in
action would believe that uh but you
know this is an example of you know
somebody who's trying to start a
dialogue and then you have these fringe
groups on the side demanding that uh she
condemn and just wholeheartedly
endorse
their particular views
sophie richardson michelle bachelet's
attitude seems to be that any
interaction with the chinese government
is better than no interaction
and that that might pave the way for
discussions around human rights policies
or what's your what's your take on that
do you do you think there's any
reasoning there well look
for a long time the reasoning has been
you know not just with the chinese
government but with others that there
has to be some degree of engagement
uh in order to push for any sorts of
improvements
and in the pure abstract the idea of
establishing working groups or dialogues
uh would be fine if there's a two-part
answer here
if 25 years of those kinds of exercises
between various governments u.n agencies
and others with the chinese government
in order to try to improve human rights
had actually yielded results they didn't
what they did was gave the chinese
government a very easy
diplomatic box to check
that assured those authorities that they
would not be held accountable
for human rights violations and i think
that's part of what has at least as a
political matter paved the way for the
thinking that we can see in those leaked
government documents that the chinese
government commit atrocity crimes and
expect to get away with it
so to have those kinds of conversations
now and for those to be the outcomes the
sole outcomes of this visit without also
excuse me
the important uh component of an actual
investigation based on ample evidence of
some of the most serious human rights
crimes committed by chinese authorities
against uyghurs and others across the
country would be an enormous mistake
this is precisely the formula that that
the very chinese officials who are
responsible for crimes against humanity
want they want to not be held
accountable
and that is what bachelet cannot be
uh allowed to let happen okay uh brush
on abbas
for those uh left behind for those
leaguers who are still in jin's young
what is life like there now how much
surveillance is there or how are people
feeling
the chinese government basically
criminalized islam and it's used as a
weapon against innocent people
they are being treated not just as a
secondary citizens and they have
absolutely no any kind of basic survival
rights but they are facing
active full-speed genocide
we just had thousands of pictures
documents of chinese government's own
data
showing how ridiculous china's faulty
claims when they are saying that
those are so-called training centers and
for the national security issues there
are faces after faces of young children
like 14 15 years old teenagers
73 years old grandma
60 some years old 70 some years old
people what kind of national threat
somebody like that
all the grandma's
grandpas brought to a country
like china
so basically
uh what the the uyghur people are living
is about survival they are fighting for
survival
and the uh what the bachelorette did
is legitimizing the chinese government's
genocide and it's going to make oyga's
life hell there what she did is the same
as going to nazi germany doing during
the early 40s and repeating what hitler
was saying about the jewish people in
europe
so she should be ashamed of herself and
resign immediately if she has a little
bit of humanity left in her heart i know
tangent what do you make of the
international response
to china and to these uh allegations of
what's happening in xinjiang
well the international response has been
mostly on the the u.s side which is a
decided uh obviously uh roushon and her
groups are saying this uh they're joined
in the course by uh human rights watch
uh but you know it's a little bit of a
stretch uh you have to believe that
china is an uncaring uh country that
doesn't do anything for its people when
it's in fact uh one of the few nations
who has done something about poverty has
provided
upward mobility has provided
resources social services to its people
one of the greatest economic stories out
there so this beating the drum that
somehow chinese people are repressed and
unhappy uh they might be under covered
restrictions right now but you know the
fact is that's not true and i i think
anybody who comes there i have been in
um
xinjiang last summer i did not see
people crying and being repressed i
made it a point of getting out and going
off on my own
so that i was not being monitored so i
could see the situation i saw none of it
in fact in kashgar i couldn't find any
police although there are many more
cameras than there were before i was
there in 2015
and the hotel where i stayed was bombed
about
less than a week after i left
at that time there were armed guards
there were checkpoints there were
armored vehicles people with machine
guns
but none of that was there when i got
went back last summer and quite frankly
the people had changed i've been much
more middle class and much more
concerned about getting their kids into
college i visited a maternity hospital i
wanted to see what was going on there
and i can tell you that no one was
telling them to
not have babies we met with families
we weren't introduced to them we
literally went up to them and just said
hey can we talk to you
and uh it's very clear to me at least on
an anecdotal basis that there is no uh
repression going on there which i i know
that sort of um ability to operate
independently has been very difficult
for
international observers or would-be
researchers i'm we're gonna have to
leave it there for time uh thank you
very much for your time uh roshan abbas
i know tangent and sophie richardson and
thank you two for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page says facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vanel and
the whole team here in doha bye for now